a gift from Turkey to the UK a quarter
of a million pieces of personal
protective equipment mores needed but
this flight last Friday was the first of
a growing NATO effort to help allies to
help each other NATO command structure
different NATO mechanisms are providing
a significant to support to NATO allies
coping with their community crisis that
may be so but archrival Russia was
faster at grabbing headlines with its
aid plane loads of assistance for Italy
though some view this as more
geopolitical gesture than genuine
generosity China too quick to help
including here in the UK
it seems that NATO has really been quite
slow to respond and the response itself
has been quite limited and quite
peaceful are you actually worried that
NATO is a bit on the back foot here and
is allowing countries like Russia and
China to step into that space and be
seemed to be the great rescuers of the
countries of Europe the NATO started
early to respond but the most important
thing we did in the beginning was of
course to implement preventive measures
protecting our missions and operations
but because it is important to remember
that NATO's core task is to make sure
that this health crisis doesn't become a
security crisis
this is one of those security missions
British forces in Estonia the Alliance's
eastern flank they're deployed to deter
Russian aggression but what about Moscow
softly-softly approached to win friends
during the pandemic NATO needs to wake
up we need to have a collective attitude
Ward's international security otherwise
like I say there are many states and
non-state that will take full advantage
of the vacuum that we're creating it's a
unique challenge counter the virus and
counter attempts by adversaries to
exploit the crisis lots to discuss when
NATO defence ministers meet remotely on
Wednesday
Deborah Haines Sky News